these killings that take place where
normally the head is decapitated because
that's the highest form of retaining
honor for a family because a girl is
showing her hair worn the wrong clothes
had a boyfriend been too westernized or
like me left a forced child arranged
marriage
[Music]
that's pretty lost I'll be honest with
you you know I lived for my parents
because we're born in my culture that
you live for your parents you serve your
parents and we all want to belong to
something and I knew that now I'd left I
was completely a black sheep of the
family and I was going to be hunted I
was going to be looked for I had to
avoid all people from my culture because
they would look for me and continue that
on a killing attempt because I brought
shame upon the family and the way they
look at it is if you leave an arranged
marriage they have to kill you to retain
that honor so I
went to a women's Refuge where they
placed me from the hospital and everyone
there had their own demons they were
dancing with they were relying on
alcohol and substance abuse and I was
too
I was too naive to understand that these
people are also suffering I didn't have
that emotional intelligence that they
are suffering I couldn't help them
because I couldn't help myself and I
begged the warden to give me some money
so I could get to my friend and when I
arrived there her boyfriend opened the
door and I said oh where is your
girlfriend can I please stay and he said
we have two rooms so you can stay but
we're no longer together she decided to
go back and have an arranged marriage
I
was really grateful but he said that I
had to get a job and pay rent so I did
get a great job in the local Council and
you know I was still healing my arm was
still in the sling and my hip was very
um would give me a lot of trouble
one day he said to me do you want to go
to a party because the landlord was
having a party and I'd never been asked
to go to a party or been to a party and
we didn't really communicate very well
because he did his own thing I did mine
which I kind of quite liked I was used
to that being on my own I remember
watching people because there was a lot
of people there
but he handed me some a Coke
um a drink and I said thank you I
remember that night going back to the
flat and the door opened and I remember
falling straight down and I remember
nothing after that
but later on I realized that I was
pregnant and I was being sick my periods
had stopped and I said to him I think
I'm pregnant and he said well don't you
remember the night we came back you
really wanted to do you know sleep in my
bed and I said no I don't and I realized
that he'd raped me and taken advantage
of me
but I wasn't focused on that because to
me I didn't match in that respect
because I had no self-worth or
self-respect
but I actually started to think about
their baby and that it would give me
something to focus on and wouldn't it be
nice for me to have something
and
the pregnancy went through he
was never really involved in my life he
lived in the same flap
he wasn't really excited he asked me to
get rid of the baby and I said I
wouldn't and I gave birth to my first
child a beautiful girl
and she was a girl
which meant I could break that
generational curse of not celebrating a
girl
and I remember in hospital holding her
and I was on my own
in saying to her that I would protect
her
that I would give her so much love
because my mum had told me what I
shouldn't be like as a mum she had
taught me all of the things that I
craved for
so I decided I would be that perfect
mother for my daughter
I later on discovered that my brother my
father my brothers and my father came
looking and they got wind that I was
living in that flat and they got wind
that I had had a child out of wedlock
which is a very big Taboo in my culture
my father was wearing a blonde wig
apparently and they were going to abduct
my daughter and kill her
and I stayed in and I didn't go out for
months because I was too scared and even
when I did go out I would look around
and make sure my surroundings were safe
and that became a habit and it still is
that habit
on my journey started to change because
I was determined to make a good living
for her
and I went into business and I started a
mobile phone shop from my flat and which
made me a lot of money which made me go
and get a shop in the Town Center which
made me known to the town center because
people would come to me there was nobody
doing that in the town at that time I
progressed onto buying another property
I progressed on top of my second child
my son
and when he was born my relationship
started to change because my partner was
happy that I'd had this boy and I
thought well this is good because I'm
not going to leave him even though I
didn't have a relationship with him and
we didn't share the same bed often and
we didn't go for dinner dates and sit
and eat together or even talk but that
was normal to me he asked me for money
because he was going out and I used to
give him sometimes between five to eight
thousand pounds a month for his expenses
he didn't work
and he became very violent pushing me a
lot pushing me down the stairs pushing
me in the wall grabbing my hair and
pushing it into the passenger side if he
was driving
every 11 o'clock at night my door would
be locked and every five o'clock it'd be
opened and I
had anxiety from those sounds of a door
locking
but I was too scared to leave I had
children right where was I going to go
and could I make it on my own even
though I was running several businesses
and I was at that time A Millionaire I
felt I couldn't do it because I was
always told I was too fat too ugly
stupid and that I was lucky to have him
so whatever capacity whatever little bit
he gave me I would grasp and hold on to
it and make excuses for his bad behavior
and I didn't know I was in a violent
situation until things were very serious
and when I was pregnant with my third
child and I was seven and a half eight
months pregnant and he pushed me down
the stairs
oh sorry
I fell
and he left
and I remember not feeling my baby move
anymore
I remember checking myself when there
was a foot
and I got to the hospital
and I gave birth to the most
beat
most beautiful little boy
who I call Tyler
but he died shortly after birth I
remember lying there and wishing it was
me that I'd not him
whilst listening to other babies crying
around me because I was in this
Maternity Ward all alone
and I asked God at that time
why why have you taken him from me
and I really fell into about of
depression whereby
I did not want to live
I knew I had the two children
I knew I had businesses to run and
people relied on me to get their wages
Bonita was tired of being a provider
Nina was tired of life
and I kind of stopped living
I didn't see my children for days
there was a little ceremony because my
partner refused to accept he was even a
baby but I carried to him I felt him
move
I held him when he was born
um
when I got home I wanted to scream to
the well to stop
but the world just carried on
but I couldn't
and I begged my partner that I wanted
another baby he was really not happy
because he was having other
relationships and didn't want anything
to do with me and said I was so
disgusting that no man would ever want
me and that I was lucky that he even
looked at me because I was so disgusting
and I begged and begged and begged and I
got pregnant this time I was sure it was
a little girl
because I wasn't gonna have three boys
in a row and when I got to hospital I
said to them can you put me in a pink
room and they said well
what's wrong with this room and I was no
I want to be in a pink room and I
remember making a really big issue and
then I had my baby and it was a little
boy and when I held him it was almost
like I had Tyler back
um but I knew it wasn't
in a way he gave me that reason to live
again
in that moment in that time I did my
best and my daughter went off to
University
and she started to come back and
question things and say I don't like the
way you treat my mum and her dad would
say right you're not coming back anymore
and our communication severed we
couldn't communicate he would go to see
him and I couldn't and I really missed
that
and I used to think the children didn't
know what was going on because I was in
a separate room but domestic violence
isn't just happening to the person it's
happening to the whole family
and it destroyed the boys it destroyed
them in a way that they couldn't do
anything but they heard every threat
they felt every punch they almost went
through it when I did
and my son stood up to his father for
the first time and I actually stood up
to him too because he punched my son for
no reason he came downstairs and hit him
in the back of his head
and even then I did not leave
I just was so scared of leaving
but my son was very very brave he had
had enough I think people get to a point
where they can't take it any longer and
he went to school
and told them everything it was
literally like opening a can of worms
and I suppose he couldn't stop talking
once he started and
I was removed by Social Services I had
no choice but to leave I had
literally 20 minutes to leave there was
a little window that we could go we
ended up in a emergency housing place
where the council put us and
and I remember finding a little bit of a
tissue in my
bottom of my pocket and I tried to clean
one of the beds that was cleaner than
the other
and wrapped him up in my coat and lay
him down because he was mentally and
physically exhausted and he was sick
I went into the other room and I think
for the first time my life I allowed
Nina to cry
I wasn't crying in a way I'd ever cried
before because we're told it's weak to
cry that you can't cry you know that
you've got to carry on with life
but I allowed myself to be weak and I
think it's in that weak time those weak
times that I've found my actual strength
can I remember standing up and there was
no music
and I started to dance we had no
curtains and I remember not caring about
anybody looking in and I was actually
moving so much that I felt a release
and I knew that I had to keep going for
him he had nobody but me he relied on me
I had a injunction so that nobody could
contact me but they don't really carry
much weight I'll be honest with they're
all a waste of paper and lawyers time
because it just means nobody can hit you
but they can come to your face and
threaten you and my ex-partner was doing
that so I moved over 200 miles to where
I am now
and that's when things really changed
the police came to find me and they said
to me that we need to speak to you about
your sister and I said I don't have a
sister
I discovered that my father had had an
extramarital affair with a Polish lady
and that he was trying to hide his
affair and he had had many Affairs but
this one was slightly different because
the lady had had a baby a baby girl
and when the baby girl was six years old
her name is Julia
my father abducted her
and
took her to several
places I think he traveled into Europe
to several destinations before he took
her to India where he sold it to
traffickers
and the police said that they went over
to the place he left her but they
couldn't get access to where she was and
it wasn't until maybe a year later of me
knowing all of this it really hit me
maybe because I wasn't able to
look at the information or understand
the information but I suddenly thought
I have a sister who was taken
by force and I'm doing nothing about it
and I don't know if she's alive
because the place that she was taken is
a place where they harvest organs and I
didn't know whether
she had been killed by suddenly started
seeing my own daughter at six
and I knew that she would have been so
scared
I realized that she's not my only sister
that all of those girls and women
and men and boys that were taken because
they've done something against the
culture maybe their sexual preference
isn't how the culture believes it should
be
I started to look into these things I
knew about the babies that were placed
into bags and suffocated and I knew that
in Marie Claire there was an article
that there was a baby decapitated on the
side of the road in China and people are
just walking past this baby and I said
I've got to do something
but I was scared
because I knew what would happen and my
safe space would be at risk
but I believed my journey as painful as
it has been has been for something I
don't have a degree I wasn't allowed to
get educated but this was my education
and I want change
so I started speaking out I would either
speak on the radio or I would speak on
team whatever I would get I would try to
raise awareness and nobody wanted to
speak to me about this word honor
killings
but I would write 15 to 20 messages each
day to people I would send emails I
would contact them on Instagram but
nobody wants to let me speak and I felt
like a child again where I was muted
and slowly people started to understand
what honor killings are and that they
are
something that my culture doing cultures
like it in Africa
in South America in the Middle East most
of Asia sometimes they're called
something else but they
these killings that take place where
normally the head is decapitated because
that's the highest form of retaining
honor for a family because a girl is
showing her hair worn the wrong clothes
had a boyfriend been too westernized or
like me left a forced child arranged
marriage
I speak in Parliament and I asked them
to pass a law and change the narrative
because
if I attend that day at the age of 21
looking the way I did and said this is
an attempted murder
they would have done something about it
but because anoner killing is protected
because it's a cultural
crime the sentence is less than a murder
currently in the UK what is the
situation with honor killings and and
what do you want people in this country
to know about them it's really hard to
ask for help
you feel guilty you feel like you have
to protect your parents and if you want
to do something for you you feel like
you don't deserve it but you do and what
I say to people is contact me my
non-profit contact any non-profit but
don't think that you can't get away that
you can't escape and I say to people if
you're being forced to go to another
country play something metallic in your
pockets or maybe even in your underwear
where it sets off the alarm Bells when
you go through security and ask for help
because you deserve that help
when I tell my stories it's never been
for me admittedly it started for my
sister
and then it went on to all of the girls
and men that needed my help and it's not
easy and I get upset because it's like
cutting myself open so that so other
people can heal but
this story is never about me it's for
those people that resonate with it
because they've struggled whether it's
mental health whether it's something
that's nothing to do with my culture
because my non-profit is open to
everyone I don't want them to feel that
they can't contact me some of the
messages I get is I've not found anyone
to help me I'm not from your culture but
can you help me
predominantly I speak about honor
killings and human trafficking because
it's happened to me directly with my
sister and myself and child marriages
and child abuse but what I do this for
is so that other people know they're not
alone because often I felt I was alone
because I was that bad spirit that
didn't matter so I would like anyone
who's out there listening to this to
know that there's somebody out there for
them and that somebody is me but also
that there are a whole load of good
supportive people that will help you but
you have to ask for that help
I am working really hard I am on a board
at Scotland Yard I go to Parliament and
I've spoken recently to West Midlands
police in a conference and I'm due to go
to Cambridge Police too and my message
is always the same I ask them are you
listening because I don't think people
are listening that can make a change to
people that can Serve and Protect US and
the message is let's abolish this word
on a killing let's replace it with what
it is and what it is is an attempted
murder or a murder
a couple of days ago and I've not said
this
one of the victims I've been trying to
help escape from the Pakistani heritage
on the outskirts of London
was killed
in a hit and run
whilst her two young girls and a
suitcase
sat at a bus stop because she was trying
to escape
I'd been speaking to her for months
trying to
support her my non-profit was offering
her a taxi a train ride I would put her
up somewhere I would help her
and somehow she must have had an
opportunity to get away
and the police rang me because her last
call was to me
and I try to explain to them they need
to do something but they said there is
no proof and this is where we as a
society fail the victims this is where
the police who are supposed to protect
and service fail because the laws that
are not passed to protect people
and those two girls that she has will
not be protected
how is your relationship with your
identity changed over the years I used
to wish I was the boy sat next to me or
two spaces beside me at school because
he was this white British boy that
everyone loved and liked I used to wish
I was one of the men in the office
because they were more respected I used
to wish I was my brothers
but when I hit a certain age I realized
I would be nothing if I was one of those
people the only person I was ever meant
to be was me
I celebrate myself as a woman I
celebrate my life because I love
everything that's happened to me which
sounds odd to people but I wouldn't be
Nina without that trauma without those
tears without that fear I wouldn't have
the ability to help her this so
I love everything that nobody ever loved
about me more and I will continue to do
so
[Music]
all my life I'd been threatened that we
will bury you under these floorboards
and I really believed they would and
within no time they had broken my jaw
they had
broken my arm and
I was in a lot of pain